i was looking at your your resume your
resume is very impressive starting five
i mean no no you're starting five
is is very impressive
i mean this objectively like
[Laughter]
who smokes the yogurt thrower the best
[Laughter]
objectively but just out of like a pure
talent and skill did you have sugar
before this yeah
i'm like bread i don't know what's going
on
yo drink breakfast
drink breakfast
two grams of sugar this isn't who drank
prime the best like who
[Music]
[Laughter]
who had the god-given talent
um for you know
yeah
yeah
is there one person is there one for
some
just objectively objectively you know
what i'm saying yeah who could who could
mayweather not go around
[Laughter]
who is for real right yeah
you know some are somewhere
they they stand out i know say what they
some stand out right um
i'm not sure i can say though you know
i've been
what was the question
but there was one there was one i'm not
going to say this beautiful talented
entrepreneurial young lady's name okay
the problem i have with what's going on
you keep throwing around the word
talented
that's a talent bro
that's a
taking smeckle to the face bro that's a
talent i'm not that talented
that is a talent i'm saying some some of
them are designed by god with a mouth
that is better for token yogurt yeah do
i feel what you're saying exactly
i get you you get like you have a lot of
skills that are god-given bro like yeah
you work hard can't suck dick though we
don't know
we don't know that as far as i know what
i mean we don't know that you've never
done pottery how do you know if you're
gonna pop you're right
what i'm trying to say is their girls
have been talked about you i saw a clip
of a girl talking about you busting
quick
it happens
right though it happens it happens when
the throat is crazy you know what
happens what is this is bad go when i
don't give a [ __ ] whoa
[Music]
no
make that dj noise stop drinking
listen what is that i have one he's got
one
it's the problem
it's the prize i promise
the prime does bring something like that
let me explain okay please please yeah
when i care about a girl like i really
care it's important to me that the
pleasure is reciprocated and everlasting
oh you go down there everlast i'll do
whatever do you like eating box a lot uh
the right box yeah the right bun yeah
it's very important that she can go
south quick yeah
well what's the criteria
i mean that's tricky it's just love
for
just what's the criteria for a good box
yeah yeah what do you love
baby no there's a lot there's a lot
there's a lot of things that can go
wrong yeah um
smells or like i mean that's
you know keep going taste oh everything
really yeah i mean were you actually
like you don't know this i don't know
i'm [ __ ] larry david don't go down
say what you don't go down no of course
i go down what are you talking about
none of my wife
no but of course bro i'm out here going
down i dress like hillary clinton dude i
eat [ __ ]
come on dude
carpet butcher
but yeah of course of course i do that
[ __ ] you know when i was in my 20s or
whatever yeah but now as an adult you
know you got respect for the ladies
yeah
yeah
yeah
no i believe in going down i do believe
that you should 100 you should i also
believe that there are some girls that
just have a [ __ ] gift man
at
going down
what makes that [ __ ] percent um i
literally don't know what it is because
sometimes they'll be looking like
they're doing the same thing that the
other girl does
but it doesn't have the same effect can
i tell you what i think it is okay i
think it's a innate enthusiasm
it's the love for the game bro please
i think i think i think if a girl is
enthusiastic about making whatever man
she's with happy yes game changer if you
like what you're doing if you like what
you're doing you'll never work a day in
your life that's a trip
that's a famous quote mark twain said
that
we gotta do a compilation of whim with
mark
[Laughter]
rogan mark says to watch it and rogan
gave him a pound and you can see mark
going clip it
yeah yeah
when george when george hugged six nine
or a depth of six nine when george hug
garyvee he loves the clip he loves the
clips yeah it's a good conversation it's
an interesting conversation i i think i
agree with you enthusiasm is the key
it but it comes it comes from a desire
to please some girls have it some girls
are like are like
natural givers does that love that yeah
no i'm saying yes and um
personally i'm i'm
i'm like like for real grateful when i
come across
one of those it's uncommon by come
across do you mean like
[ __ ] man